we kind of touched on this earlier but
how have your expectations
of the business changed since going to
nyu tisch
being a filmmaker this sort of journey
that you've had
how have your expectations of making
films and pleasing the audience changed
i i the whole process of making films
and has kind of been what i thought i
know would always be challenging
i think you have this idea that once
i think anybody in any career especially
in entertainment
there's never like i made it there's
always going to be
more challenges like you're always
scrapping to get your next movie
you always set the bar higher you don't
want to do more of what you did so
i think the one thing that surprised me
that you're always
working hard to get your next movie um
and the other part that i think
i think is a weird thing that's gotten
worse
i think it goes back to the internet i
don't think
film critics should be film critics i
think they should be film enthusiasts
and i don't think um
the setup of the job right now is they
feel like they have to critique
and say what's wrong i think we'd all
benefit more
um if it was a film enthusiast and they
would look for films
that you need to see because all the
ones that are
popular and commercial honestly i don't
even look at the tomato rating my movies
don't always get reviewed very well
people seem to be
they don't like adam or they do like
adam that doesn't help
um i look at the audience response if
anything
you know i'd rather call somebody i know
that saw the movie but i
i i think the audience is leaving
theaters saying what they thought
is a more accurate gauge if a movie's
good i think
um it's weird how critics will feel like
there's certain movies they have to like
and they don't like and
and and if if they weren't critics and
their film enthusiasts
their job would be great because they
would list a bunch of movies that we all
need to see
right now there's probably 10 movies
that aren't going to get a whole lot of
press
and they're probably really some good
ones and i would rather read the article
like oh i'm going to go see that
movie because i i
that filmmaker would never get seen so i
just wish it was more like that when you
go back to the
there's a kaiju cinema it was uh was um
truffaut and yadara the new wave they
all had
they were filmmakers reviewing other
movies and it was much more
about embracing what they liked and less
about
taking pop shots at you know if you
don't like a movie too i also think if i
was a reviewer
i'd be like look if you like action
movies that do this this and this you're
gonna be happy
but i think reviews are just generally
are just
just you know trying to cut it down or
just
they just decided okay we're gonna like
this movie and and say we like this
movie
you know it's funny like when the water
boy came out
they talked about how sophomoric it
wasn't how there were so many fart jokes
and i was like there's not a fart joke
in the water boy you can say sophomoric
that's not your opinion and and at the
time um
the farrelly brothers had did the um
kingpin
and and they embraced it which was
really funny great movie
but i mean that one had fisting bulls
and like they had full-on
so it's like the it's not an honest
um you know nobody's from it's not an
honest uh
system so i i think there should be film
enthusiast
so when you ask me about the filmmaking
that that's one of the things
that that disappoints me and um yeah and
that you have to always fight to get
your next movie or work really hard to
get the next one
do you think the same way with social
media and we're outing people and we're
putting our thoughts out there there's a
power in trying to take things down
there's definitely a negativity um that
that seems to
excel um and and i don't know how we
have to reinvent it but
i guess it starts with each and every
person and you know listen as an artist
that's what i'm gonna
try to make people as long as you have
integrity
as long as you're everything that goes
back to integrity if you have integrity
you're not gonna take a pop shot at
somebody and you're gonna give a
balanced argument or
i don't like this for this reason but
you might like it you know if you're
more
if people are more fair i think we'll be
okay
um it's that lack of of seeing the
person's face that you're
you're picking on that the internet does
that
that causes it you know louis ck did the
whole thing about how
he doesn't want his kids to have a phone
because when you're a kid
your tendency is to punch a kid in the
face and then the kid starts crying and
then you realize oh i feel bad and then
you form empathy but on
a phone you punch a kid in the face by
saying something mean but you never get
that response so
it's that lack of of being able to form
empathy
that that's that's missing with the
internet i don't want to take technology
away
i just wanted us to elevate ourselves to
be better people to be able to handle
our toys
do you think most film critics should
have gone to film school yeah i'm not
sure the background i haven't done
research
i mean my feeling and i don't want to
sound like
i feel like a lot of them went to film
someone that they just didn't apply
themselves to make movies
and so there's a frustration i i'm not
everybody there's some
people that just love films and and but
the feeling i get you know is that
you know it's sometimes i'll write back
to a
film critic and they're very not angry
i'll always be like oh there's somebody
who wrote something about
um blended and and i was like well my
intentions weren't that
i in a very straightforward way i was
like i tried to make something that
wasn't typical i wanted to make two
people falling in love over parenthood
not and then the guy wrote back like i
forgot the directors of human beings
it was such a great feeling i was like
because i'm like
i felt really bad because blended by the
way people love that movie kids love
that movie
and the it's one of the few times that
the critics they don't usually bother me
but there's three amazing kids in that
movie that are more there's one two
three there's five kids in the movie
and they loved the movie they loved
making it
and they loved the premiere and they saw
the people laughing and loving the movie
and they couldn't wait for the reviews
and i was thinking oh these poor kids
are going to get their hearts crushed
and
and they did and they were just like
they couldn't believe that the movie got
shredded you know
uh to pieces and i feel like why don't i
wake up around to me it's
probably 15 or something and uh it's not
fair
like that movie is not if you i don't
care what you say that movie compared to
a bunch of other movies that got
higher ratings it was it delivered on
what it was supposed to do and
so it bugs me when like people that are
critics are just so easy to be like
that this movie's
predictable and this is that and that
you know that kind of thing but even the
great critics do it if um
siskel and eber is really funny if you
go back to um
the waterboy interview that might be
online um
ebert was like
he kind of gave it like a like this
movie was
not great it was sophomoric and then
siskel goes
i can't believe you and i go oh my god
he's gonna like the movie
he goes how did you even watch it and i
thought well
that just says exactly what's wrong like
you can't
say that you can't go in that bias
wow so it's not always fair but i
i for me what matters is how people feel
and the ultimate um
[Music]
validation for me is my movies are on tv
for 20 years
and they run over and over and over and
uh and i can't say that about a lot of
the other movies
that came out those years so that that
that would i in
and in the long run that's what i that's
what matters i'm like i don't know i
can't
guarantee a movie's gonna get reviewed
well i can't even guarantee it's gonna
you know make a lot of money i just know
i'm gonna make a movie that's gonna be
emotionally honest it's gonna be a story
that i think is important
and it will probably have a shelf life
it's a wonderful life was the reason i
wanted to make movies and
my parents were you know they're in
their 80s so they're like oh my god that
movie bombed when it came out because it
was depressing
it came out after the war and then i was
like oh my god this is like
the classic of all classics and i was
like i always go to that like oh good
the movies don't have to do well when
they come out they have to do well over
time
and that's the true test
you